living a european lifestyle may not be
out of reach for stressed out overworked
americans but only if you're willing to
stay the course and of course pay up you
could be on your way to eu residency the
ceo of the points guy sat down with
scarlet foo with details on exactly how
to attain the very powerful eu passport
and he lays out all the perks as well
this is presented by american express
frequent travelers often dream of
holding a second passport that can ease
the hassle of applying for foreign visas
when you're the founder and ceo of the
points guy that means realizing a
lifelong dream of obtaining european
union citizenship allowing one brian
kelly to travel freely throughout the
european union you had to get crafty so
what's harder hypothetically obtaining
lifetime titanium credit card status or
eu residency
uh eu residency they're the europeans
love their paperwork that's for sure i
work through a law firm called the
mercan group they specialize in portugal
they have investment products across the
country instead of buying an apartment
building which is kind of complicated to
do i was able to invest in a renaissance
marriott hotel in porto and i'm one of
180 investors who put in 350 000 euros
each and we're all part owners of this
new hotel and you know about a year
after applying for uh the golden visa
residency i got my card this summer but
the reason i chose portugal is that hey
you only need to stay there for about a
week a year for the five years of your
residency before applying for the
passport most countries make you stay
for about 183 days there were countries
like malta but malta you kind of have to
give the country a million dollars and
never see it again i wasn't that in in
need of a passport the thing about
portugal is uh in this investment i i
spent 420 000 i earned three percent a
year on that investment not great but
not horrible right uh and then at the
five year mark when i get my citizenship
they automatically give me my initial
investment back oh interesting okay i
got to ask about taxes because that's
going to be a huge headache what what
how are you thinking through that
so portugal does not charge you taxes uh
on because u.s is one of the few
countries in the world with global
taxation so you're not going to get
double taxed you know in general it
doesn't really change the tax game
unless you renounce u.s citizenship how
much of this process did you fund with
your credit card and how many points did
you get from it i tried trust me scarlet
but yeah lots of international wires
unfortunately like i like to say it
never hurts to ask ryan kelly the points
guy thank you so much and congrats once
again on becoming a portuguese resident
[Music]
all right well now i know what i need to
do for my next passport application
that's going to do it for now but i'm
madison mills in new york and stay right
here with more quick take ahead